like some things that i just
don't
you know didn't really
pay attention to you guys are touching
up on it and it's uh
it's good that's why we wanted her on
the show so we could uh
so she could just listen to us
it's like immediate validation yeah
it's like we want to know are we doing a
good job for you guys
and we have her here to be hot and
beautiful and to give us approval you're
welcome
hi i'm ryan wright and i am jerry and
i'm andrea welcome to reasons to see
where we give you reasons to see or not
to see ender's
game so let's hang out
reason to see number one
ender
so ask kiss butterfield he is awesome in
this movie sure he appreciates that yeah
no seriously awesome
it's not that it's a it's three letters
it's ass ace of butterflies regardless
he does a great job in this movie now
amazing ender is the [ __ ] i wanted to be
this 13 year old kid man he starts off
with growing up on board games and like
if it made sense to me when i was
watching i was like yeah thanks perfect
yeah motivating his character his leader
from start to finish it was awesome i
didn't know how much i would like him
given the trailer because he seemed kind
of cold and stiff but in the movie you
you get to know him and sort of this
whole situation he's thrust into and he
does give a standout performance in this
movie i mean there's a lot of good
performances but he's
stellar yeah he's the best performer in
this film like you could feel all that
repressed anger and stuff he seems to
really embody every part of this from
the passion that he has for what he does
does you know the strategicalness the
tacticalness those are not words and
also like just the being
caught in between so many things yes
exactly you know and and uh you could
feel all that like internal struggle
that this kid goes through you know even
though you know he's the [ __ ] and
somehow he's gonna figure it out you're
you're still like
rooting for him this entire time you're
the [ __ ] ender so what did you think of
ender's performance andrea it was
it was [ __ ] amazing it was
it was what word were you originally
going to say
you went shh
[ __ ]
[ __ ] shocking it was [ __ ] amazing
what can i say it was [ __ ] amazing
reason to see number two directing
the director of this is gavin hood gavin
hood the director of x-men origins
wolverine and he has needed a movie for
a while to break that image and he has
finally done it with ender's game i
really wanted to see him do well and i
think he does with this movie i think
his direction especially like where he
puts the camera and all that stuff and
the pace is is good you know to step up
from uh it's like a whole staircase up
from x-men origins i loved how he played
with so many different themes going on
in this movie there's such heaviness in
a lot of these subjects but it keeps the
film moving at such a fast pace to keep
it entertaining throughout you know i
don't know if they did that just because
i have to trim the story down
significantly you know there's like
tonal shifts that occur when with
different characters come in and the
transition to that makes so much sense
it's captured so well so uh what do you
think of the directing
uh directing um
two thumbs up
get sued by abram
reason to see number three visual
effects
i thought they were awesome you know the
second movie i've seen this year where i
was
based in space and i love
you know anything
that deals with me
so how do you feel about kevin's space
well i mean it definitely took me in to
you know
deeper belief
that's what she said it's not like you
know groundbreaking visual effects in my
opinion but it's still pretty damn good
visual effects it's a sci-fi epic it
most of it is in space there is a heavy
use of visual effects but you know it's
it all feels like it goes to serve
what's going on you know it's all for a
greater purpose than just oh shiny
there's nothing that looks
cheap or cheesy everything's done really
well it kind of feels like star trek at
times doesn't it like the old school
star trek not not the abrams version i'm
talking about
enter
you will save up so what did you think
of the visual effects andrea spacey blew
my mind it was you know it took me in
and uh rolled me around
that's what she said
or something along those lines oh come
on tip you in and roll me around
did you put you in the laundry this way
that way up and down
more of what she said she was
commentating on everything that was
going on reason to see number four
harrison ford
more and more these days harrison ford
to me sounds like like a grumpy bowl of
oatmeal dude his hair is he's starting
to bald but he still looks incredible
for his like he he just looks like
harrison ford with older he looks at
least like 10 years younger than he is
but as far as his performance goes like
uh
i was i was blown away not no take that
back i wasn't blown away he wasn't the
main character so he wasn't in like the
whole movie that's why that's the shitty
thing about the trailers the trailer
makes it look like it's all about
harrison ford you still get a heap ton
of hairs on the board though yeah like
your main support yeah he's not like
just harrison ford is like making a
cameo like he's he's really in it he
does a really good job i'm not like oh
dude yeah harrison ford is the reason
but you know he's still good he's still
really good what i thought was cool
about him like looking back on the
performance is he was very human at the
end of the day he could have played this
like all smirky and like ooh i'm the
suspicious character instead it's he he
he made a very human performance at the
right times you trust him at the right
times you're questioning his intent he
doesn't like put on an act at any of
these moments like it's still the same
character and he's in love
with this 13 year old boy ender he is he
like every other line is henders amazing
yeah it's like i imagine if we got any
other scenes in this movie of just him
hanging out he would be like at a bar
somewhere going i gotta tell you about
this kid yeah we got this kid ender he's
awesome
he's drunk in that scene yeah what do
you uh did you like harrison ford what
do you think uh yeah harrison ford was
pretty cool um intense in the eyes
um intense in the body
intense with the other characters you
see intense in the body intense in the
haircut too
the haircut was pretty nice were you
were you physically attracted to
harrison ford no i'm saying
intense in the body as in he had body
confidence he was a leader he was
strong he was and he showed it and the
way he stood and the way he presented
himself
it sounds like he was going for a job
interview
reason to see number five
viola davis
she is african-american yeah clearly in
this movie she is clearly right clearly
african-american she played an
african-american character really good
no she was great in the movie she was
she was wonderful yeah she's the perfect
balance for harrison ford's character
kind of like a sports therapist in a way
you know she's there to like really help
these soldiers
you know deal with their pain and trauma
so they can advance more and everything
i think they represent ender perfectly
because you got harrison ford who's more
closed off from his emotions and is like
[ __ ] like [ __ ] all emotions just do what
you got to do and then the other one is
like no be in touch with who you are and
trust yourself and all these other
things and so ender always has that kind
of struggle to try to be both those
people she's actually like just pound
for pound my favorite performance really
more than ender he's great but she just
every time she was on screen she really
stood out to me is just being so natural
so what did you think of
african-american actress viola davis ah
african-american
she's african-american viola
i like that name
viola that's what she got from this
movie very soft in her demeanor he's a
great supporter of the children she
supported the [ __ ] out of the leading
cat reason to see number six action
there's not a lot of action in this film
but there's enough to be satisfying and
there's not a lot of action but there is
a lot of training for action yeah
exactly there's this one it's kind of
like
space quidditch in my
opinion that's what it reminded me of
harry potter yeah it's like it's got a
harry potter hunger games feel about it
well because it is a young adult novel
aren't those porn novels no decidedly
not lit erotica is a completely
different uh erotic novel right i think
you're thinking of an adult novel not a
young adult i hear young adults i think
of a category on pornhub.com sorry
there's this one moment where it's like
i don't want to give away the game they
have some great moments especially where
ender gets looked like a total badass
you know not just you know
intellectually you know he does some
physical [ __ ] that's like
this guy's a gangsta homie yeah that
whole compton sequence was crazy yeah
it's it's at one point it takes a real
different direction yeah
for like 10 minutes only where ender
just kills a bunch of gangsters but no
the action was was really it was really
cool it was very cory it was
choreographed really well too there's
just enough action it seems like it's
all merited by the story and it's
captured really well you know yeah for
people going for that you know those big
sci-fi you know spaceships and laser
guns and stuff like that you know yeah
you will have your film it's a fun film
dude it's it's fun i had a i had a great
time yo
some actions maybe what did you think of
the action did you like the action
yeah
yeah um the kids they fought
a couple few times
um and it kind of it was kind of scary a
little bit because they were so violent
with each other and you know kicking
each other's asses and it was greatly
coordinated i i have to say
and
the cool game
the awesome space game that they did
that was a lot of action and um flipping
and
shooting and
this stuff and that
interesting reason to see number seven
the writing
i haven't read the book so people don't
hate on me but uh overall i thought the
writing was really cool you know the way
uh all events played out that they had
to deal with a lot of different themes
throughout the way i was all handled i
thought they i thought they made a good
you know little
little ball about it you know yeah i
mean from what i've heard about the book
it seems like it is it's at least a
competent adaptation it's just shy of
two hours so i feel like it could have
been longer if it wanted to but you know
for what it is i think they get
everything out and the only thing i've
heard people complain about is just that
it's not as deep as the book but it does
touch on some interesting ideas that are
more than you're gonna get from your
average transformers movie i can see how
people might get upset about that but i
thought like it was an entertaining film
with enough depth so what'd you think of
the writing andrea well
um
since it was a great movie
it was great it had to be great writing
ah
so uh
i i mean writing was really good i
thought
my opinion there's a question there's an
interesting question for the end of the
show sometimes like have you ever seen a
great movie
that you thought was like poorly written
but everything else about it is so good
it was great
not that this is but you know just
yeah that the writing had way more it
could have had more potential no no i'm
saying i'm not saying that this movie
was like that ryan's consensus ender's
game is the reason movies are made
ender's game is the reason movies are
made yeah i just had a total blast and
it was like enough depth for me and
everything i did anything that i found
there's there's obvious flaws about it
but it just added to the fun for me i
kind of enjoyed the flaws jerry's
consensus a solid enjoyable sci-fi epic
is the reason to see ender's game a
solid enjoyable sci-fi epic is the
reason to see ender's game but yeah i
think it's definitely you know a step
back up for gavin hood and i'm glad to
see him you know do well and i hope uh
andrea's consensus this stuff that jerry
and ryan said was the reason to see
ender's game the stuff that jerry and
ryan said is the reason to see ender's
game yeah well i walked out of that
movie feeling like a leader it was
a thoroughly pleasant experience in the
cinematic world
yeah alright guys thanks for checking
out our review for ender's game why
don't you go ahead scroll that comment
box below and tell us
would you name your kid ender and once
you're done answering that yes or no
question come on over here and click
this button so you can see more episodes
of reasons to see and once you're done
doing that watching all of our videos
you are a dedicated fan my friend
follow us on twitter because you're
going to want to see more videos right
and we let you know when our video is up
and follow us on facebook and we can
interact you talk to us we'll talk back
we're not like other youtube douchebags
yeah and uh once you're done with all
that stuff because we are demanding
you're gonna want to get updated every
time a new reviewer video is out right
so if that's the case
subscribe click on andrea
right there yep at the chest area that's
where you want to click
just put drag that mouse over there
and do it it's the best game that game
you won't end there is a a game
involving a mouse in this movie yeah
and gavin hood played the giant really
yeah
gavin has a film director andre yes i
know this okay you don't need to get
defensive or in front of the camera
right now
and the fact that of course i know this
you always do this every single time we
hang out you always just get on my ass
well maybe you shouldn't
you know say things
that are stupid
you